[Music]
show me your
put your hands up
put your hands up do it now
put your hands up
hey get sticks over here with us now
we need sticks with us hey go get sticks
mark
get my trunk my trunk get my trunk
stop
in the truck
put your hands up hands up put it in
park now
close my trunk actually 162 see there's
somebody close to the sticks i've got
some on my houston olive
is out of service people get out of the
way
yeah he ran my car
stupid
[Music]
take her and put her card
hey ferg can you coordinate
[Applause]
give me a status on injuries too i've
got a couple of
what they got uh
that's how you're good
go ahead
[Music]
okay nothing
[Music]
what's your address
so your name's courtney what's your last
name courtney
[Applause]
over here
[Applause]
we got one
gonna give that to them yeah
they're okay
all right so tight buddy
he's on that side okay you okay bud
please take care of him okay
you okay
you see what happened i just came around
the corner
we were chasing that lady that's in the
backyard of that house right there oh my
god you got a squad started right
okay
yeah yeah have a seat relax
no just leave it there for now all right
man have a safe day
ti come out they're on the right okay
well i'll have john do the measurements
if he's going to help who's working the
fence oh obviously graves not even no
secrets left i think he went because i
guess this lady mowed down somebody in
the city shop
so he's going back and then seagraves
got ahead of the coalition
or call the city and see what you all
wanted to do yeah we'll get uh was it a
city car that hit it or was it the it
was this
suv yeah
yeah we finally it was a girl oh
yeah she ran my car
yeah well i tried to block her in right
here with my car long ways
and i don't know if you guys look but
she i was hiding behind your light pole
because i thought she might try to run
us over
and she hopped that curb right there oh
that's what she did i left just enough
room where she skipped the front of my
car and then she made it through there i
was like dang it we almost had her
so yeah we thought she was gonna ran
through that gate yeah
yeah i mean she came through that field
over here
and it was like that was crazy it was so
anyway i was like i was like man like i
hope she doesn't hit anybody
well i'm sorry she hit your car do you
have your driver's license on you
uh i'll do a collision report on your
car there and
we'll see if she has insurance hopefully
she does
yeah
yeah honestly i thought she had one of
our cars because the car that she has we
have the exact same car color and
everything really
thank you
yeah there's her parts right there okay
yeah that got a little western there for
a minute it man she ended up driving
through the walmart parking lot for like
10 minutes
hauling through there and then so i
guess you left here went that way
uh no she went out i think she if i
remember right she came out this way and
then went south got back into walmart
for the second time
all over and then
she ended up
doing like a hundred down aspen and then
turned on 91st and then for his
daughter's work the church was on
lockdown
wow that was right there by panera we
were thinking about locking the gate so
yeah yeah
well she probably just smashed it open
she's crazy man
i i thought she was going to run me over
i was hiding behind your pole like
all right lady come on this thing's
sitting in concrete let's do it let's
see i thought she was actually going to
go through that gate over there because
we have this entrance and then there's
an entrance over there yeah
he's gonna run through it yeah
this is crazy